Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P here is a guy who
really doesn't like that. I talk and comment when
I do coverage of rallies. Last night we covered
we tried to cover the Bernie rally and we covered
the Trump rally. And this guy doesn't like that.
I sometimes say things and he makes an interesting
point about my qualifications to have an opinion.
Speaker 5: You're laughing because you're
part of the problem and you've never been
overseas or you've done a shit on your skinny
little ass and done nothing with your life.
Speaker 1: I've been overseas plenty of
places. I've been dozens of countries.
I don't know what they're talking about.
Speaker 5: Except talking to a microphone.
You've never squeezed a trigger on anybody.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's true. No. If he means
I haven't been overseas with the military killing
people that. Guilty as charged. I have never shot
anyone. The caller is correct about that. That
being said, I don't know why I need to have shot
people or shot at people in order to have opinions
about things. That's strange. I don't know where
else this individual applies that. Mr. Dentist,
I know you want to do my root canal, but have you
ever squeezed the trigger at people overseas?
You haven't. Oh, well, I don't mean. Okay.
Very, very dangerous and sick people. We
have a great bonus show for you today.
Twitter has started advertising its
paid verification plan for $8 a month.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: We will indeed talk about it
on the bonus show. New York City employers are
now requiring salary ranges to be posted. I like
this. I like this even as an employer. And I'm
going to tell you why. And then lastly, the U.S.
Defense Intelligence report on UFOs will soon be
made public. I will tell you what some people are
expecting, what I am expecting, and we will delve
into it a little bit more. So much going on in the
next 24 hours. The election is tomorrow. I will
be live tomorrow night starting between seven and
eight Eastern on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook with
election results. We're going to go for a while.
I don't know how long. I hope you will join me
tonight. We will be live with multiple rallies
starting at 7:30 p.m. Eastern, also on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook. It is all happening on those
platforms, so it's all free. I'm selling you
nothing. Follow us on Twitch for free. Subscribe
to the YouTube channel for free. Like the Facebook
page for free. So then you can get if you want,
you can get notifications when all of these
live streams happen. A very, very big 24 to
36 hours in American politics that I believe
will be of massive consequence going forward.
See everybody then. And of course, to get today's
bonus show. Simply sign up at join Tap McConnell.